TO THE ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMUNITY
HEARING DISORDER LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF THE SOUTH THAT HAVE MADE
OUR RETURN TO THE CAPITAL TO
HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE AND SURE A
FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOOK
LOGISTICS OF OUR HEARING TO
HELP PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE. HERE TODAY AND ALSO
TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS
TO THE DISCUSSIONS. DUE TO THE
CONTINUE STAY AT HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND- PUT TWO. EIGHT HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING. WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE
CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. THAT
BEING SAID WE WILL ABIDE. BY
TYPICAL COMMITTEE PROCEDURES
AND HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND TO IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S FINE FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. A FEW OTHER
OPTIONS ARE. FULL WITNESS
TESTIFYING TODAY. ARE TODAY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICAL THE DISTANT.
IN PERSON HEARING IN THIS SPACE
WE CAN ONLY OF SODA. LET'S SEE
HOW ABOUT. AND THEN YOU CAN
EXIT THE HATE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING WILL
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATE THE MODERATED DOWN
TELL FULL SERVICE. THROUGH
WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY
ON A BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO YOU. CAN ALSO FIND
HIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE WEBSITE WELL
AS ON THE TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO. AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU ORTEZ FINE ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON. HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES- MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST.
SMART THIS IS TO REDUCE TO
SOUND DISTORTION. ALSO THE
COMMITTEE. IN ONE SIX THREE ONE
NINE. TWO TWO IS. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY. WITH THE MODERATOR
FULL SERVICE AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LATER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR APPEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT THAT BUT THAT'S TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. ALSO BEING MINDFUL
AND RISK. OF PUBLIC EXCEL
HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL FACE.
WITH THAT THOUGH WE CAN NOW
TURN TO- ONLY BILL BEFORE US US
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM-
WILL PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THE BILL IS SB NINE EIGHTY.
JUST AS A QUICK REMINDER FOR
THOSE WISHING TO REGISTER.
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BY
THE PHONE. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CALL IN NOW AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE SENATORS TESTIMONY TO AVOID
ANY DELAYS. THE PHONE NUMBER
AGAIN IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO SO WITH THAT THAT WALKED ON
SENATOR. UMBERG GOT ANY TIME
YOU. MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU.
THE RIVER GOT IT DID THAT WORK
THANK YOU. SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION SENATOR PLACE TO
BEGIN THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF FIRST OF ALL
MISTER THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY ONTHIS BILL- I KNOW
YOU'VE DEVOTED PERSONAL TIME
AND YOUR COMMITTEE IS DEVOTED
SIGNIFICANT TIME TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE- I WILL BE
ACCEPTING COMMITMENTS ALTHOUGH
I'M GONNA SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
TWO OF THOSE AMENDMENTS. HERE A
LITTLE LATER ON. THE PURPOSE
THIS BILL IS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS PRIVACY WHEN THEY-
PURCHASE A DIRECT TO CONSUMER-
GENETIC TESTING KIT- MANY OF US
HAVE DONE SO I'VE DONE SO MY
FAMILY'S DONE SO. IT'S VERY
INTERESTING RESULTS BUT YOU
WANT THOSE RESULTS TO SAY
PRIVATE YOU DON'T WANT THOSE
RESULTS TO BE DISSIPATED-
PLACES WHERE IT COULD. WORK
ADVERSELY TO YOUR INTEREST SO
FOR EXAMPLE TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT. INSURANCE OTHER
AREAS. TO THIS BILL IS DESIGNED
TO DO IS TO PROTECT. YOUR GENET.
AREA OF BEING LEASED WITHOUT
YOUR SPECIFIC CONSENT. AS
ORIGINALLY ALERTED SORT OF THE
ISSUE ONE OF A MEMO LATE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WAS THE
SEVENTY BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE THE THAT WARN MEMBERS
OF THE MILITARY NOT TO UP
PROVIDE THEIR GENETIC MATERIAL
TO DIRECT TO CONSUMER TESTING
COMPANIES BECAUSE IT COULD BE
IS FOR SUBVERSIVE PURPOSES THAT
ALERTED ME TO THE FACT THAT
THAT PERHAPS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD LOOK INTO IT IT.
FORMED LOOK LATER N US AT.
EIGHTY SPIN ISSUES IN THE BILL-
ONE IS THE ISSUE OF DARK
PATTERNS ORIGINALLY THOUGHT
THAT WAS A NETFLIX SERIES BUT
IT'S NOT IT ACTUALLY- AND I
THINK IT'S DESCRIBED QUITE WELL
IN THE ANALYSIS- THE DARK
PATTERN IS A USER INTERFACE
DESIGNED OR DELAYED WITH
SUBSTANTIAL EFFECT OF SUBURBAN
OR IMPAIRING USER METONYMY. OR
CHOICE FOR DEFINED BY. WHAT
WE'VE DONE IT IS WE HAVE A
ADOPTED THE DEFINITION OF A
DARK PATTERN AS IS CONTAINED IN
THE C. P. R. A. WHICH IS AN
INITIATIVE THAT APPEAR ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER- IN
ANTICIPATE THAT YOUR PASSAGE WE
WANTED TO BE TESTED WITH WHAT
WE'VE LOST LOCAL NEXT YOU ARE
THAT. IN THIS STIFF NECK
PORTION INITIATIVE DOES COME
THE TWENTY TWO. BUT IT'S REAL.
BOB PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR WHATEVER YOUR INTERFACES
IS NOT DECEPTIVE THE SECOND IS
WITH RESPECT TO CONTEXTUAL
ADVERTISING- CONTEXTUAL
ADVERTISING. IS ADVERTISING
THAT IS DIRECTED TO A CONSUMER
BASED ON CERTAIN INFORMATION WE
DO NOT WANT I DO NOT WANT I
THINK MOST FOLKS DO NOT WANT
ADVERTISING DIRECTED TO A
CONSUMER BASED ON THEIR GENETIC
MATERIAL SO FOR EXAMPLE. IF IT
TURNS OUT YOU- AGE OF THE
DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING COMPANY AND- IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU MAY HAVE A CERTAIN
ILLNESS OR CERTAIN GENETIC
PROPENSITY. YOU DON'T WANT THAT
TO BE RELEASED TO A THIRD PARTY
SO THAT THEY CAN DIRECT
ADVERTISING CONCERNING THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE DISEASE
WHATEVER IT MAY BE- HOWEVER. IF
YOU SIMPLY ARE IF THE COMPANY
IS SIMPLY PROVIDING-
INFORMATION OR ADVERTISING
BASED NOT ON THE GENETIC DATA
BUT BASED ON THE FACT THAT
YOU'VE ENGAGED WITH YOU KNOW
FILL IN THE BLANK DIRECT TO
CONSUMER- ENTITY. THAT WOULD
NOT IN MY VIEW THAT WOULD NOT
BE VIOLATIVE OF YOUR- RIGHT TO
PROTECT YOUR GENETIC.
INFORMATION AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT
BUT THIS STILL REMAINS A AN
ITEM OF SOME CONTROVERSY AND
MISTER CHAIR YOU AND I
DISCUSSED CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT ISSUE- SO. WITHOUT FURTHER
DELAY US FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAU SENATOR-
LET'S NOW GO TO LAWS OF SUPPORT
DEL WITNESSES SO STARTING WITH
THE MARINE MAHONEY WITH THE
CONSUMER REPORT I BELIEVE THIS
TESTIFYING REMOTELY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO WALK ON ON THIS
ABOUT ONLY. WELCOME TO THE-
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M-
POLICY ANALYST AT CONSUMER
REPORTS AND WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTING AS BE NINE EIGHTY
BECAUSE IT WOULD PROVIDE
IMPORTANT PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
OVER UNIQUELY SENSITIVE DATA-
THIS DATA CAN PROVIDE INSIGHTS
INTO WHETHER YOU OR A FAMILY
MEMBER MIGHT BE VULNERABLE TO
CERTAIN THIS THIS. AND CONSUMER
STRONGLY VALUE- THESE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
CONSUMERS RECENTLY SIGNED OUR
PETITION CALLING ON LAWMAKERS
TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY AND
SECURITY OF THE STATE UP.
MILLION CONSUMERS HAVE USE
THESE TESTS TO IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL HEALTH ISSUES MANY OF
THEM LIKELY ASSUME THAT THIS
HEALTH RELATED DATA IS COVER BY
STRONG HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS LIKE
HIP HOP. OR CMI AA- WHICH
REQUIRE CONSENT FOR MOST IS
CLOSER. TO THIRD PARTIES
HOWEVER DIRECT TO CONSUMER
GENETIC TESTING COMPANIES. IN
CALIFORNIA REGULATED CHIEFLY BY
THE SEA CPA IN WHICH STUDENTS
ARE DAHLE MODEL COULD ALLOW
THESE COMPANIES BY DEFAULT TO
LEGALLY SELL DATA TO THIRD
PARTIES. THIS WILL REQUIRE
COLLECTION SECOND USE AND
DISCLOSURE OF THE STATE-
IMPORTANTLY THERE'S A PROVISION
GIVING CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO
REVOKE CONSENT PUTTING
CONSUMERS CORALINE CONTROL. IS
ALSO A STRONG DEFINITION OF
CONSENT WHICH INSUES THAT
CONSUMERS CAN MAKE MEANINGFUL
CHOICES WITH RESPECT TO THIS
ERA. AND DATA SECURITY
PROVISION WHICH IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN LIGHT OF SECURITY
BREACHES OF THESE COMPANIES IN
RECENT YEARS. INCLUDING ONE AT
CHEN MATCH IN THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS. ALREADY STATES LIKE
ILLINOIS AND MISSOURI HAVE
STRONG PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OVER
THE STATE UP. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS HAVE THE
SAME AND WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS I
BELIEVE IS JOHN VERITY WITHOUT
FUTURE OF PRIVACY FORUM ALSO.
VIA THE TELEPHONE IS- MISTER
VERY ARE YOU ON THE LINE. ON
THE LINE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
TO CREATE THAT PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU A MONIES JOHN
VERDY I AM VICE PRESIDENT
POLICY AT THE FUTURE OF PRIVACY
FORM WE ARE A- NONPARTISAN NON
PROFIT THINK TANK IN WASHINGTON
DC. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SAFEGUARDING CONSUMERS GENETIC
INFORMATION. SB NINE EIGHTY
WOULD CREATE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND STANDARDIZE
EMERGING BEST PRACTICES FOR
DATA PROTECTION IN IRAQ. TO
MERGING EXIT. I NEED IN MY VIEW
WOULD DO THIS IN A WAY THAT
COMPANIES CAN OPERATIONALIZE.
WHY DO I THINK THIS WELL. I
THINK THIS IS A WELL BALANCED
APPROACH BECAUSE LEADING
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTING THESE SORTS OF
PROTECTIONS AND SB NINE EIGHTY
WOULD EXTEND THOSE PROTECTIONS
WALL CONSUMER. FORGET COST THE
STREET. IN JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE FUTURE PRIVACY FORM
RELEASED BEST PRIVACY BEST
PRACTICES FOR CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING SERVICES. WE DEVELOP
THESE BEST PRACTICES FOLLOWING
CONSULTATION WITH TECHNICAL
EXPERTS REGULATORS. LEADING
CONSUMER GENETIC AND PERSONAL
DRAMA TESTING COMPANIES AND
CIVIL SOCIETY. THESE BEST
PRACTICES INCLUDE STRICT
STANDARDS FOR THE USE AND
SHARING OF GENETIC INFORMATION
GENERATED IN THE CONSUMER
CONTEXT. INCLUDING STRONG
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT HOW COMPANIES COLLECT USE
AND SHARE GENETIC INFORMATION.
REQUIREMENTS OF EXPRESS FUHRMAN
OF CANCER AS A BASELINE
REQUIREMENT FOR COLLECTING
GENETIC INFORMATION. SEPARATE
EXPRESS CONSENT FOR THE USE OF
GENETIC MATERIAL OUTSIDE THE
INITIAL SCOPE OF COLLECTION.
SECONDARY EXPRESS CONSENT IS
ALSO REQUIRED BEFORE COMPANY
ENGAGES IN ON WILL TRANSFER
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL INFORMATION.
AND FPS BEST PRACTICES AND SB
NINE EIGHTY WOULD PROVIDE
STRONG INCENTIVES TO DE
IDENTIFY DNA DATA TO BETTER
PROTECT IT- AND ALSO GRANT
CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
CORRECT OR DELETE GENETIC
INFORMATION. SB NINE EIGHTY
WOULD LIMIT SHARING WITH
ENTITIES LIKE EMPLOYERS ARE
INSURANCE COMPANIES EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WITHOUT A CONSUMER'S
CONSENT. RISKS CAN ARISE
SHARING THAT ARE TOP OF MIND
FOR CONSUMERS AND I'LL SAY A
FINAL WORD ABOUT THE MARKETING-
PROVISIONS OF SB NINE EIGHTY IT
IN ITS VARIOUS FORMS I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK ALL
DAY THE REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE DONE TO
NAVIGATE THESE DIFFICULT ISSUES.
HAPPY WE FOUND. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE A GREAT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND ALL IN OR OPT
OUT CONSENT FOR SENSITIVE DATA.
WE'VE ALSO FOUND ON THIS
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE INCENTIVES AND LAW
INDIAN RULE ON FOR COMPANIES TO
AGE IN LESS INVASIVE. NON
INVASIVE ADVERTISING PRACTICED.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT COMPANIES
MAKE A CHOICE BETWEEN OBTAINING
OPT IN CONSENT. FOR MARKETING
BASED ON VERY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION WILL PROVIDE OPT
OUT CONSENT. OKAY BASS ON WHAT.
GEN FOR ENGAGING IN TAX
ADVERTISING IT TYPICALLY DOES
NOT USE INFORMATION ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL BUT RATHER TARGETED
ADVERTISING TO THE CON OF THE
WEB PAGE OR INTERNET- WE THINK
IT'S A HEALTHY THING FOR THE A
LEGAL SYSTEM TO PROVIDE TENNIS
FOR COMPANIES. TWENTY LESSEN
TRUTH FOR BETTER TIES AND
RATHER THAN MORE INTRUSIVE
FORMS OF ADVERTISING. ONE FINAL
NOTE- I WOULD FLAG THAT IN IN
THE VERY STRESSED THE BILL I
KNOW FOLKS ARE- MOVING TOWARDS
CONSENSUS LANGUAGE- AROUND HOW
TO HANDLE ADVERTISING IN A
CONTEXT- OF CONTEXTUAL
BASEMENT- AND I THINK THAT
THERE IS THERE IS MORE
CONVERSATION PERHAPS TO BE HAD.
ABOUT THE EXACT SENATOR OF
THOSE EVER. WAYS THAT CAN BE.
COMPLIED WITH BY COMP. AND ALSO
WAY USED IT IS FORMALLY PROTECT
CONSUMERS SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
FOLKS ARE ARE FOCUSED ON ON THE
NITTY GRITTY WORKS NOTHING OF
WHETHER A PARTICULAR
ADVERTISEMENTS ARE INTENDED- TO
BE SEEN BY CERTAIN AUDIENCES
ARE EXPECTED TO BE SEEN BY
CERTAIN AUDIENCES. I THINK THAT
THERE IS A FURTHER. BEST FRIEND
THOSE RULES THAT THEY CAN
BECOME. TO MARS AND
APPROPRIATELY IMPLEMENTED BY
COMPANIES I THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ARE CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS WHAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR VERITY ELSEWHERE
TESTIMONY BEFORE WE GO TO THE-
NEXT WITNESS LET'S ESTABLISH
OUT QUORUM. CHANNEL KILEY THEIR
POWER CAN HAND HERE BERMAN YOUR
CALDERON CARILLO GABRIEL GALA.
IRWIN PRESIDENT OBERNOLTE THREE
MEN HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM I IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
BILL HERE IN THE ROOM FORTY TWO
OH TWO. PLEASE A. COMFORT THE
ONE TO OF A MAN THAT THIS AFI
SURE FINE I AM GLAD WITH ON THEOF ANCESTRY AND THREE ME IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION-
WOULD LIKE THE BILL AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THAT THE BILL ONLY
RESTRICTS CONTEXTUAL ADS THAT
ARE INTENDED TO RESULT IN
DISPARATE EXPOSURE TO ONE GROUP
OVER ANOTHER AND THIS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED ON PAGE NINE NINE
SEVEN BY STRIKING RECENTLY
EXPECTED AND INSERTING INTENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM. HOW ABOUT
THEIR SUPPORTERS ON THE PHONE
LINES. MR OPERATOR GOVERNMENT
UPON LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE UP PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO THANK YOU. GET PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE'LL HAVE ONE AND ONE
MORE THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM WINE NIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS THAT
ARE ON BURKE IS A SERAPH LOCAL
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE HARD WORK OF
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
BILL AND YOUR SUPPORT OF UC'S
RESEARCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE. MR
OPERATOR. HELLO LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTEEN YOU
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
WOULD BE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION WEREN'T SUPPORT IF
AMENDED CONDITION WE DO STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LIMITATIONS OF NEW AMENDMENTS
AS WELL AS DEFINITION IN THE
NEW AMENDMENT I'M WILL CONTINUE
WITH THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU LETS SO NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE THE FIRST
WITNESSES MR CAMERON DO NOT
WITH TECH NET ARE YOU ON THE
LINE SIR. FOR WE'LL COME BACK
TO HIM. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
MISTER DILLON HOFFMAN WITH THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION. VIA
TELEPHONE ARE YOU ON THE LINE
SIR. I THANK YOU BEST THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
DILLON HOFFMAN DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR INTERNAL LOCATION- I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES SB NINE
EIGHTY- UNLESS THE COMMENDED TO
ADDRESS. FINISHES AT YOUR HEART
EARLIER REGARDING NON
PERSONALIZED CONTRACTUAL
OPERAS- WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO THE
MOST RECENT LANGUAGE- AND%
REALLY WANT TO RECOMMEND THE
HARD WORK- YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
AUTHOR THE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL SIDES OF
THE ISSUE HAVE. CONTRIBUTED WE
BELIEVE. IS NECESSARY BUT
CLARIFY THE FINAL IS WITH THAT
ARE COME. WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT SOME THAT THEY CANNOT
INTENTIONALLY PLACED
CONTRACTUAL OFFERS IN ORDER TO
TARGET ONE GROUP OVER ANOTHER-
AFTER A WRITTEN COMPLAINT WOULD
BE PROHIBITED FROM PLACE AN AD
THAT MIGHT BE BACK. TO BE SANE
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE- BY ONE
GROUP THAT ANOTHER- JUST GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE- WITH. LIKE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ADS
FOR ADDITIONAL HELP
INFORMATION- ABOUT PIC BREAST
CANCER. NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
EXPECT THAT WOMEN WOULD SEE A
TAB THAT MAN- ANOTHER COULD BE
THAT- OFFERS OUR ADS OR LINK
CERTAIN. INFORMATION ABOUT
ALZHEIMER'S OR OTHER FORMS OF
DEMENTIA I WOULD BE PROVIDED
BECAUSE- IBM- COME DISTRICTS
MORE PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY TO SEE THE ISLAND SO. WE
ARE WORKING. YOUR STAFF THE OFF.
PRETTY. SB NINE EIGHT YEAH TIME
THANK YOU FOR YOU VERY MUCH OF
HIS TOP IS DIMITRI YET ON THE-
FROM TECH. WRITING ELSE FROM
TECHNO. IF NOT THEN LETS SO.
SEE IF THERE'S ANY ONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL IN THE ROOM
FORTY TWO A TO ANY OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KRISHNA
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION TIA WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH CENTER ON
BURKE IS STAFF AND YOUR STAFF
TO RESOLVE A REMAINING CONCERNS
THAT. YOU VERY MUCH THIS.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WAS ON
THE LINE. AND TO. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE
WILL GO TO ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS OF HIS CAMERA DIMITRI
ON BEHALF THE TECHNET I'M SORRY
THAT IT THE NUMBER WAS PROVIDED
WAS NOT WORKING INITIALLY. THE
TECHNICIAN HAS BEEN IMPOSED ON
US IN A POSITION ON SB NINE
EIGHTY WE APPRECIATE THE CALL
DOCTOR TO PLACE PROTECTION
DROWNED BIOLOGICAL MATERIAL AND
THE GREAT WORK YOUR STAFF AND
DOWN TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
RELATED TO THE EQUATION OF DARK
PATTERNS LANGUAGE AND HAVE
PROVIDED AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THIS. THE CURRENT BILL
INTRODUCED INTO DARK PATTERN
STANDARD THAT IS RIGHT IS NOT
FOUND IN THE EXISTING STATE
STASHED ACROSS COUNTRY. I DON'T
FACE TO ANY. ISSUE INTERFACE
DESIGN WITH THE- AFFECT HAVE
BEEN. USER ECONOMY. DECISION
MADE OR CHOI AS TO BY RAY.
DISAPPEAR TO INVALIDATE ANY MAN
OF. EVEN IF DESIGN INNOCENTLY.
YES OF IMPAIRING USER ECONOMY
OR CHOICE. ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL DEFINES CONSUMERS ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. AS A
RESULT THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK A BIT SWEEPING DEFINITION
COULD PREVENT CALIFORNIA
WONDERS STRUGGLING WITH THE
DIFFICULT TASK OF SAFELY
OPENING FROM CONDITIONING RE
ENTRY TO THE EMPLOYERS PROMISES
ON EMPLOYEES OR CONTRACTORS
CONSENTING TO THE COLLECTION.
OF IN NINETEEN MEDIC PASSED.
THIS IS KEVIN CLOSING THE CAN
FOR ENTIRELY BALLOT PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSES DESIGNED TO
PROTECT OTHERS IN THE WORKPLACE
GOOD IMPAIR YOUR ECONOMY ABOUT
WHETHER TO AGREE TO A TASK. IF
THE COMEDIAN OFFICE STATE EVEN
THOUGH THE SPECIFIC MENTION OF
COCA NINETEEN HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM TE BILL. AS MENTIONED IT
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE KOBE
NINETEEN CASTING THAT COLLECT
ANY GENETIC INFORMATION. FOR
MORE ALTHOUGH THE- LANGUAGE
INTENDED TO BE CLEAR AND SHE
ONLY. THERE'S PROCEDURE IN THE
FOR CAN NATURAL MAKE QUICKLY
THE BILL APPEARS NOT TO DELAY
THE EFFECTIVE PAN PROVISION ON
A CO COME OF THE ROOM. AS ALL
EVEN OF THE OFFICIAL IN UNDER
PATTERNS WHICH APPEARS TO BE A
IN TEN TO BE TIED TO THE CPR AT
WILL MAKING IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHICH VOTERS HAVE YET TO
ACT ON. IT EVOLUTION. IT TURNED.
OUT TO BE. THAT FROM THE JENNER
CODE IN. PASSED AND THE
CONDITIONS VOICE CONTRACT
RETURNING TO THE WORK. THIS
SORT OF UNCERTAINTY ARTISTIC TO
ME. A WORK. IT'S KIND OF. FOR
BUILDING DIRECTED PROTECT
CONSUMER PRIVACY AGAINST.
PRACTICES THAT ON SCREEN
GENETIC TESTING. WE AGREED THAT
THE DETECTIVE METHODS. OBTAIN
CONSENT SHOULD BE INVALID. WE
ALSO AGREE WITH PROHIBITION
BEGET SECONDARY USED TO
GENERATE TESTING DATA. FOR
THESE REASONS WE HAVE TO THE
COMMITTEE AMEND THE DARK HIDING
PROVISIONS COULD. NOT BRING.
BASED FISHING IT IS OUR GONE IN
FACT. IF YOU KEEP REGARDING
INTENTIONAL COULD NOT. MAKE
THAT I'M QUITE. DECEPTIVE
METHODS. TO CAPTURE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND IF YOU
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THIS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE- FALL
PHONE NUMBER THAT YOU WERE
GIVEN THAT WAS INCORRECT-
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
THAT'S IN OPPOSITION TO BILL
PLEASE. IDENTIFY HEALTH. IT
WILL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE FICON. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO. THANK YOU.
COLONEL AT PARTICIPANTS CUED UP
IN OPPOSITION. YEAH.
MR
OPERATOR. ANYONE ELSE ON THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANT NOT TO
HAPPEN IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME SIR VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF HIS PROPERTY- OF
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS MISTER BERMAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND WANT TO
APPRECIATE AND THEN SAY THANKS
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
BEFORE AND I THINK THIS REALLY
IS- AN IMPORTANT ISSUE- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING HARD ON IT AND
THAT. YOU CAN SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME WORKING THE OPPOSITION AND
WORKING WITH THE- PRIVACY
ADVOCATES- TO TRY TO. BE A
REAL. BILL ACCOUNT TO YOUR
BALLS. BEING THIS A LINK IN
SOME ON ON INDEED AND THE BIZ
THAT WILL BE IMPACTED SO IT
SEEMS LIKE IT COMING IN THE
COMMITTEE- YOU YOU HAD A GOOD
COMPROMISE BILL THAT LIKE IT
HAD UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND
EVERYBODY WAS ON BOARD AND SOME
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED- THAT.
INITIALLY CREATED SOMECONCERN
THAT IN OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
A SECOND ROUND OF NEGOTIATIONS
AND THE A LOT OF THE- INDUSTRY
AND A POSSIBLE OPPOSITION IT
SEEMS TO BE COMFORTABLE ON 9%
OF IS THAT WE HAVE FOR US TODAY
A NUMBER THERE'S REALLY THIS
ISSUE OF THE IN THE TEXT WHAT
AS MID SECTION. THEY'RE NOT WE-
WORDS EXPECT VERSUS. IS ALL IN
DESPERATE EXPOSURE AND IS
RARELY RARELY DO WE SEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SUCH A BIG
IMPORTANT COMPLICATE. AND
CHANGE. TWO WORDS AND REPLACE
IT WITH. ALMOST EVERYBODY WOULD
BE IN SUPPORT NOT EVERYBODY I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
GROUPS THAT MIGHT STILL BE POSE
BUT BUT THE COMPANIES THAT WILL
BE IMPACTED THE MOST- WOOD ALL
THE SUDDEN FLIP FROM FROM
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED TO SEE OR
FOR THE BILL SO I JUST WANT TO
TRY TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF YOU KNOW
WE'RE- WE'RE TO. FROM WOULD IF
YOU WANT COMMITTEE I. IN THIS
REASONABLY X. LANGUAGE WOULD
ALSO LOVE GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE AUTHOR-
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT EITHER YOU
HAVE A PREFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO OPTIONS OR IF YOU'RE A BILL
IT TO TYLER OPTION FOR ME AS I
KIND OF DIED THINK OF WHAT I'M
pALL AT THE EARLY RETIREMENT
MAYBE TURN OVER TO THE AUTHOR
HE HAS ANY QUOTE- RESPONSE IT
OUT BEFORE I DURING. AND I
THINK 90% OF THE BILL HAS COME
pTO. A VISIT OF ACCEPTANCE BE
DESCRIBED AS FOLKS ARE SEWN BUT
NOT MUTINOUS WHICH IS WHERE YOU
WANT. YOUR SO. AB CONCERNING
PARTICULAR A BIT OF A LANGUAGE-
THAT THAT HAS BEEN DISCUSSED AD
NAUSEAM- I WE HAVE ACCEPTED
THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT I AM
CERTAINLY WILLING TO DEFERRED
TO THE SENSE OF THE COMMITTEE
AS TO WHETHER OF THE COMMITTEE
BELIEVES THAT THAT WE SHOULD
STOP THE TWO WORD INTENDED FOR.
THE TERM IS REASONABLE
EXPECTATION OF. WE AS WAS
ILLUSTRATED BY THE WITNESSES-
WE DON'T WANT TO PUNISH
COMPANIES SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDE ADVERTISING- IN A
GENERIC FASHION TO ALL THE
CONSUMERS WHO HAVING GATE. IN
CANCER AND IT HAPPENS THAT YOU
THAT YOU RECEIVE AN AD
CONCERNING SOME SORT OF- BREAST
CANCER ISSUE- IT IF IT'S NOT
BASED ON THE INFORMATION
DERIVED FROM THE GENETIC
TESTING IS SIMPLY A GENERIC
IT'S DISSEMINATED TO ANYBODY IS
ENGAGED AYE AYE I DON'T THINK
THEY SHOULD BE TAPPED. AND I'M
IN A YEAR. WE DEFINITELY MAKES
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
ISN'T USE OR ABUSE BY THE
COMPANY'S BUT WE ALSO DON'T
WANT TO INHIBIT THE COMPANIES
TO THE POINT THAT THEY CAN'T
YEAH PROVIDE. USEFUL
INFORMATION TO THEIR THEIR
CUSTOMERS- JUST SO LONG AS
THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY USING THE
INFORMATION THAT COMES BACK IN
THE TEST WHICH WHICH I
UNDERSTAND IS YOUR- PRIORITY
WHICH I DEFINITELY AGREE WITH
AND RESPECT- YOU KNOW WE ARE.
IN THE BE. TIRED HOME. IN KEEP
THE CAR GOING BUT WE ARE THE
POLICY COMMITTEE AND WE ARE THE
LAST POLICY COMMITTEE TO.
REVIEW THIS THIS BILL IN THIS
LANGUAGE BEFORE THE BALL MOVES
FORWARD IF THE MOVE TOWARD SO I
PERSONALLY THINK THAT IT'S AND
THAT WE- GET SOME REST. TO
ISSUE TODAY. AND NO TO HEAR THE
COP AND THEN HERE I CALLED TO
HAVE TO SAY ABOUT IT BUT- I
DON'T NECESSARILY THINK THAT
IT'S OUR ROLE TO JUST KINDA.
BUT THE CONVERSATION. IT I CAN
YOU KNOW THE- WHETHER CHANGE
TODAY SO I'M CURIOUS TO HEAR MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE TO SAY WHAT
WHAT THE CHAIR AS THE SAME TURN
WHY. THE COMMITTEE MIGHT I AM
NOT A REASONABLY EXPECTED
VERSES INTENDED- BUT I
PERSONALLY I LEAN TOWARDS
INTENDED- BEING THE RIGHT KIND
OF MIDDLE GROUND- FOR THIS
ISSUE WHERE WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THE CAR IS ARE ABUSING
MISSION THEY HAVE. THEY'RE
STILL ABLE HELPFUL. EVER TO
THEIR COST SO FEDERAL. YOUR
BACK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
BERMAN LET'S GO TO MR OBERNOLTE
NEXT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
CENTER THANKS FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS. I WONDER IF YOU COULD
WALK US THROUGH. THE NECESSITY
FOR THE BILL FROM THE STATE OF
LOS FREEDOM HORRIBLE'S THINGS
THAT COULD HAPPEN. YEAH THERE
WAS A MULLIN. USE THIS GENETIC
DATA SO- I MEAN YOU'VE RAISED
SOME SOME INTERESTING. CASES IN
THE BILL FOR EXACT. COUNT. IN
THAT CASE IF THAT WAS OF
CONCERN TO ME AS A CONSUMER I
COULD JUST PICK A GENETIC
TESTING COMPANY WHO HAD PLEDGED
NOT TO DO THAT. RIGHT SO I BUT
I KNOW THAT THEIR LARGER
SOCIETAL WAS INVOLVED I WONDER
IF YOU COULD JUST TAKE A MINUTE
AND TALK ABOUT- WITH C. AS IS-
THE EFFECTS OF THIS. THAT THAT.
A GREAT QUESTION. WHAT WHAT. DO
IS TO. MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONSUMER PROVIDES INFORMED
CONSENT. SO IF THE CONSUMER
WISHES THEY HAVE THEIR-
INFORMATION DISSEMINATE WHILE
IN SOME MAY. SO MAYBE ONE OF
YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE RECEIVE
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT PERTAIN TO
A PARTICULAR GENETIC. MAKE UP.
THAT'S JUST NEED TO CONSERVE TO
THAT. THE GOOD. NEWS IS IT IF
YOU HAVEN'T CONSENTED. THEN
YOU'RE IN. BY THE- BACK. MO OF
THE BE COME TO DO TO CONSUMER
TESTING DO ABIDE BY A CODE OF
ETHICS THAT IS LARGELY EMBODIED
IN THIS BILL SO I DON'T WANT TO
CAST ASPERSIONS AN INDUSTRY
WHERE THAT'S NOT WHAT TO OUR
SON OUT LIARS WHO THE AMPLE MAY
PROVIDE THEY'RE NOT PRO SECURE
THAT CAN BE ACCESSED. ALL SORTS
OF- WILL JUST DIDN'T SORT OF
DOING. DO YOU ALLOW REESE. BUT
OTHERS THE THAT MAY WANT TO USE
IT TO FOR EXAMPLE IDENTIFY- A
POPULATION HAS A SPECIFIC
GENETIC PREDISPOSITION TO AN
ILLNESS. AND EVER AS TWO OR
EVEN FALSE EYES AS TO EMBODIES
THAT THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
EFFICACIOUSAND SO THOSE
CONCERNS- PERSONALLY BELIEVE
THAT. THAT WHEN YOU PROVIDE
THAT VERY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
THAT YOU HAVE A RIGHT. TO KEEP
IT CONFIDENTIAL SHOOT THE SIDE
OF. OKAY I THANK YOU I ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
LIMITATIONS ON THE USE OF
GENETIC DATA FOR SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
THIS IS A AREA OF RESEARCH AND
A LOT OF THE HUMAN SCIENTIFIC
ADVANCEMENTS TO TAKE PLACE
COUNTRY OVER A CUP OUT OF OUR
THEY'RE NOT A- PILOT GENETIC
DATA. CAN YOU BROUGH SHOULD THE
BILL TOMORROW HOW A-
INSTITUTION WOULD GO ABOUT GET
A HOLD OF ANONYMIZE DATA
WHETHER AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THE CONSENT OF
ONE THAT WAS PURCHASED. SO THE
QUESTION W WERE WITH THE
RECEIPT CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I
SHARE YOUR INTEREST AND CONCERN
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY IN THIS
TIME OF COVERT CRISIS THAT THAT
WE BE ABLE TO. HAVE AS MUCH
RESEARCH DONE AS POSSIBLE BUT
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU. PURCHASE AND
YOU CONSENT TO HAVING YOUR
MATERIAL USED RESEARCH PURPOSES
WHICH MOST PEOPLE DO. THEN THEN
IT IS NOT IDENTIFIED SPECIFIC
IN INDIVIDUAL. IT'S THE- IN
DECEMBER THAT FASHION OKAY. AND
I'M NOT LASTLY I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON A SETTLEMENT BERMAN'S
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS THIS
DIFFERENT THIS DEFINITION DEBT
DIFFERENCE IN DEFINITION
BETWEEN REASONABLY EXPECTED
INTENDED I SHARE THAT CONCERN
AS WELL I DON'T THINK IT'S
ANYONE'S IN HERE PUT
LIMITATIONS ON TEST MAYES. WAS
ABOUT AS IN THE DOOR JUST FOR.
CHECK OUT BUT IS THE END UP
WITH US WHAT WE- WHAT IT IS AT
THE OF THE DISCUSSION. AND I
HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT. I THINK IT QUICKLY
ILLUSTRATE DIFFERENT. AT THAT
WERE BEING AS THE FACT THAT THE
MORE SOMETHING. YOU MIGHT HAVE
IT ON AN OUTSIDE MIGHT HAVE A
NEXT. THAT THE TAKE RATE FOR AN
OFF WOULD BE BRENT FOR
DIFFERENT IF. SUFFEREDYOUR
PAYING A- ONE I BET. OFF TO
EVERY OUR NOT TO BE IDENTIFIED
AS BEING DIABETIC BECAUSE OF
THEIR GENETIC DATA BUT- THE
STATISTICAL DATA SOME ETHIC
GROUP IS MORE PREVALENT IN-
CONTRACTING DIABETES AND OTHER
ETHNIC GROUPS SO I MEAN IF
YOU'RE REASONABLE QUESTION THAT
THE TAKE RATE FROM. BUT YOU'RE
NOT. SO I JUST THINK TO BE FAIR
AND IMPOSE THE SAME RULES ON
THESE COMPANIES AS EXIST FOR
OTHER COMPANIES AND I THINK
THAT THAT WORDING CHANGE WOULD
DO THAT SO WHAT THANK YOU FOR.
YOUR HARD WORK. THANK YOU. OPEN
LET'S GO TO MISS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AM I TO WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR IT IS-
WE DISCUSSED PRIOR TO THIS I
HAVEN'T USED ONE OF THESE
SERVICES BECAUSE I'M SO
CONCERNED. SINCE THE COME UP.
WAS SAID BY THE WIND IS BELIEVE
THESE ARE PROTECTED BY HAVE A
AND OTHER I'M PROTECTIONS AND
THEY ARE NOT AND SO I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE TAKE THIS
STEP IN PROTECTING THIS WHAT I
BELIEVE THE MOST PER. AND THAT
NOW IS THAT. PLACE THANK YOU
FOR THAT SO WHEN I COME YOU
BECAUSE- TO MISTER BERMAN'S
POINT. NOT OFTEN DO YOU HEAR
BILLS COMMAND ESPECIALLY THIS
NATURE WHERE YOU HAVE. THE
OPPOSITION THE PROPONENTS THIS
CLOSE TOGETHER AND- WE DO IT
WHEN I'M- JOINED THE COMMENTS.
OF BOTH MISTER OBERNOLTE AND-
ONE THIS ONE CHANGE THAT IS
BEING ASKED FOR BY INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE WEDON'T WANT TO HAMPER
BUSINESS SO MUCH THEY CANNOT
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT GETTING THEM AND SAVE
INFORMATION YOU HAVE SO
ELOQUENTLY DONE IN THIS BILL WE
ALSO NEED TO. CHANGE IS
REASONABLE I'M HERE FOR YOU
THAT YOU ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
CHANGE. I GUESS I WOULD ASK MY
FORGOT THE NAME OF THE WITNESS.
WHO IS IN THE PROPOSED SPOKE TO
THIS CHANGE AND SAID THAT. HE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO
EITHER JUST SAID WE SHOULD KEEP
TALKING ABOUT IT AND- I'M-
RESPECT. I WISH. IN THEIR
EXPERTISE ON THIS YET. WHAT THE
REASON WITH THAT I AGREE WITH
MR THE SAME OR FOR THIS AND HOW
QUICKLY THINGS ARE MOVING THAT
WE NEED TO DO OUR DUE DILIGENCE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE OUT OF
HERE IN A CONDITION THAT IS
MOST ADVOCATE. CANNOT THIS
GIVEN I PER NO OPPOSITE FROM
ANYBODY ON ANY SIDE WOULD LIKE
TO ASSEMBLY PATIENTS AND IT MAY
FORWARD WITH THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR I THINK MY CHECK
THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER. STONE I ALSO WONDER WHY
YOU KNOW JOINT JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN COMMENDED YOU
SENATOR FOR READY FOR THIS BILL
I THINK IT'S A- IN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT MEASURE ACTUALLY
SHARE A SIMILAR JUST WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM AND TO WHICH IT
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN INTERESTED IN.
A IS TAP BRING SOME OF. MEASURE
ONE THAT. FRANKLY I THINK IS
NEED NEEDS TO BE ACTED ON I
COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND DOING THAT ACTUALLY WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR TODAY. I THINK IT'S
THE MEASURE. MY NAME SO. I WANT
TO SAY THAT I SHOULD THE
CONCERN AND COMMENTS OF THE
THREE COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN
BEFORE ME- ABOUT THE CHANGE
LANGUAGE I THINK THAT THE
INTENT LANGUAGES TO BETTER WE
WILL HEAR. AND FRANKLY I'M IN.
IT'S AN WE HAVE A STRONG
CONSUMER PRICE PART MEASURES I
THINK THAT YOU HAVE DONE A VERY
JOB OF A PUTTING THOSE IN
PLACE- I THINK ONCE WE PASSED
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION PIECE
AND THE PRIVACY PART HE SAID.
RIGHT THIS IS YOUR- MICHAEL.
WAY THAT THEY ARE YOU KNOW
UNLESS COME AT THAT YEAH AND
FRANKLY SO OF THE- LANGUAGE IN
THE- AMENDMENTS HERE TO ME
SEEMS TO BE A BIT ON BOARD FOR.
PRIOR INTERESTS AND HOW.
TROUBLE UNDER. WHAT PRICE
INTEREST OR FRANK CONSUMER
INTEREST IS SERVED. IN THE WAY
YOU KNOW COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR HERE TO. AND SO YOU KNOW
RATHER THAN GAS UP CAN
PREFERENCES MADE RATHER THAN
INSERTING A- AND TELLING US.
HOW CAN OFFER I THINK WE SHOULD
DRAW THE LINE AT RELEASE AND
CAN PROTECTION REAL. FIVE IN
THIS. SO I JUST KNEW I ECHO OF
MY HELP RENDON BIG BEAR AND
RESPECT WE SEE BECAUSE THIS IS
THE SOLE PRIME COMMITTEE THAT
WE YOU KNOW SO THIS THIS COMP
HERE AND I CERTAINLY WOULD BE
WORK AT THE MICRO SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BELL RESPECTFULLY
ASK TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AND SUGGEST THAT WE- INTEND
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. ANYONE AT. I CAUGHT. MR
THE DARK UP ISSUE. FOR A LITTLE
MORE EXPLANATION OF THE CHANGE
YOU'D LIKE TO SEE AND WHY EXIT
DEFINITIONS OF CONSENT AND
FEDERAL LAW- ARE YOU GO. LET'S
SEE. THAT WOULD BE A MIS
THERMISTOR. OF MEN OR MR
DIMITRI. I AVAILABLE. THIS IS
DON HOFFMAN- I DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY REYES THIS IS HERE
I DO RECALL THAT THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TECH THAT WAS
HAVING ISSUES WITH THE
TELEPHONE LINE- SO TO- COME UP
I BELIEVE ARGUED AND I YOU KNOW
PREFER HIM TO MAKE IT INTO. BUT
THAT. WHITE ALIGN MORE CLOSELY
WITH OUR EXISTING LINE FROM
TAKING WITH BE PROP BUT AGAIN I
THINK. THANK YOU WOULD MAKE
POINT NOT MUCH MORE I. ARE YOU
STILL ON THE LINE. OR SOMEONE
FROM TECHNET. I GUESS NOT.
WHICH ONE COMES BACK ALL. WE
HAVE WE CAN OUR AYE YEAH ANY OF
THE QUESTIONS MISS KILEY. OKAY
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP IN
ANYONE ELSE. LET ME LET ME SAY
THIS WELL THANK YOU ALL NO TO
THANK MY SO FOR YOUR ALSO. AND
UP YOU KNOW THESE TO ISN'T
EXTREMELY EASY AND KIND OF
THREE FOUR TWO HELLO JEANS- A
SEQUENCE AND TESTED. AND THE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEING
GENERATED FROM FROM THESE TESTS
IS BOTH FASCINATING
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PRINT%
OFF AS OF TODAY THIS MORNING
ARE THE BILL TENDS TO STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE- AND
REPRESENT THE MIDDLE GROUND
BETWEEN MEDICAL PRIVACY LAWS
CONSUMER LAW FOR GENETIC
INFORMATION AND CONSUMER
ENGAGING AND TRANSACTIONAL. THE
COMMISSION FINDS OUT RELATED TO
THE DNA SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BOB JUST THE GENERAL PERSONAL
INFORMATION VERSUS LET'S HELP
US- SO CCPA VERSUS HELP US. SO
IN IN PARTICULAR AS A MATTER OF
POLICY ALLOWING GENETIC TESTING
COMPANIES TO ADVERTISE BASED.
ON THE CONSUMERS PURCHASE
HISTORY ONLY UNDER LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SUBJECT TO
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS UNLESS
OBTAINING CONSENT IS I BELIEVE
OR WE BELIEVE IS TO APPROPRIATE
BALLOTS. NOW IS REASON. IT'S
ALSO A SERVICE. THE KIND
TEXTUAL HAVE AS WE HEARD. BY
REQUIRING PROMINENT LABELLING
OF TIES CAUGHT AND PROHIBITING.
ADVERTISE WITH MS REASON BACK
TO HAVE A CUENTA EFFECT. NOW SO
THE A IS WAY WE SHOULD USE THAT
THE REASONABLE EXPECT AND WORST
INTENTION OF STANDARD UP. I
WANNA I WANNA STRESSED OUT OF
THE STANDARD- RELIES ON THE
EXPECTED OUTCOME OF ADVERTISING
RATHER THAN. XIN OF THE EVERY
TIME TO PREVENT INDIRECT-
DISCRIMINATORY ADVERTISING
PRACTICES FROM GETTING- AROUND
YOU KNOW DISPLAY YOU KNOW THIS
IS. SOMEWHAT OF A PROBLEM THAT.
AND THE REASONABLE EXPECTATION
OF PRIVACY IS REALLY A STANDARD
METRIC USED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY ALL IT IS RARE THAT
SOMEBODY INTENDS TO
DISCRIMINATE OR CREATE
DESPERATE IMPACT WHAT WE CARE
ABOUT AND LAW IS THE FACT NOT
REALLY THE INTENT. ARM YEAH I
THINK THE COMMITTEE HAS
PROPOSED THAT DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING
COMPANY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MARKET TO CONSUMERS WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT SO LONG AS THE
DESPERATE- IMPACT ISN'T
EXPECTED NOW THIS IS THE LESSER
STANDARD. THEN OF WHAT THE
COMMITTEE PROPOSE LAST WEEK-
BUT YET STILL PROTECTIVE TEND
TO SEE CPA. AND ALSO STAND
APART THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS REALLY THE- TWO OF THE
BALLOT IN THE TO BE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CONTEXT. MEANT TO
THE ALL AND ALSO TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS. ARE IS TO-
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
BECAUSE THIS AMENDMENT ACTUALLY
WAS A PROPOSED LAST FRIDAY SO
WE NEED A LITTLE LITTLE MORE
TIME. TO WORK OUT THE DETAILS
BUT I'M DEFINITELY OPEN- TO
LOOKING AT THAT STANDARD. OB
SO. IN A YOU KNOW I THINK THERE
WAS AN EXAMPLE CITED BY OUR
INTERNET ASSOCIATE ABOUT THE
BREAST CANCER. WOMEN SHOULD THE
T. HE SAYS HERE WOMEN SHOULD
ONLY BE MORE LIKELY TO CD AT
TEN MEN IF YOU HAVE AT TIMES
BEEN IS BEING BASED ON THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION WHICH
READY IS NOT PERMITTED BUT THEY
ARE ALSO PERMITTED TO ADVERTISE
ACCORDINGLY SO LONG AS THEY
OBTAIN CONSENT FROM THE
CONSUMER SO UP TO THE- YOU
KNOW. SOMEONE IN BETWEEN C. C.
P. A. N. ALSO HIPAA. YEAH AND
THAT'S THAT'S- SOMETHING THAT
WE BELIEVE STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE BUT IT BUT I DO HEAR
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WHO
REGARDING TO YOUR CONCERN. AND
I'M COMMITTED TO MAKING OF YOU
DON'T FOR THE CHANGES TO IT
BEFORE IT GOES TO THE NEXT STOP
A WHICH IS THE PROCREATION SO
WE DO HAVE A LITTLE MORE TIME
THIS IS NOT A GOOD ENOUGH AND-
BUILT. SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME I CAN THIS
IS THE LAST. OF MEETING WE NEED
TO SEARCH FOR THIS OUT THE-
SHOULD SO I DO I DO I COMMIT
MYSELF TO DOING THAT AND I WANT
TO MEET MY STAFF TEAM TO WORK
OUT THE DETAILS BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN. SO YOU KNOW THE SURE YOU
GONNA BE RESOLVED IT'S SO. WAS
OPEN. RIGHT OR I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY. THE BILL BUT WITH
THE SUBSTITUTION OF THE WORD.
INTENDED FOR THE WORD THREE
LOOKS LIKE. SECOND WE HAVE
MISTER I DON'T THINK THAT'S A I
THINK WHAT'S APPROPRIATE IS
THAT AT THIS POINT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE ARE WORKING WITH THE
WITH THE OFFICE WITH THE AUTHOR
TO WORK AT THIS SUPPORT
POSITION. THAT WE TAKE YOU AT
YOUR WORD CONTINUE TO WORK AND
POSITION YOU'RE NOT VERY FAR
APART YOU'RE VERY CLOSE THIS
COMMITTEE GOES APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THAT I SAID ON. I
THINK THAT. IT WE NEED TO ALLOW
YOU THE TOP TO FIND THAT COMMON
GROUND I THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. AND THEN ADOPT THIS
LANGUAGE IS AN AMENDMENT- IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
INTO ALLOW YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT. AND YEAH IN THE
EVENT THAT YOU CAN'T GET THERE
THEN THERE ARE THINGS. THAT CAN
HAPPEN FROM. PASS THIS MOMENT
AS A- IT'LL PROBABLY AND ALLOW
YOU THAT. AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF TO TIE TO THIS CHANGE I
DID THAT IS WHY IS A PRO AT
THIS TIME. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TALK TO THERE WAS A MOTION
AND IT WAS SECONDED TO- DID YOU
WANT TO WITHDRAW THE MOTION OF
THE WANTED TO HAVE THAT MOTION.
ON JUST. MISTER CHAIR IN A
RESPECTFUL DISAGREEMENT WITH-
THE SUPPLEMENT CALDERON- THE
IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT THAT THIS
IS THE LAST POLICY COMMITTEE
BEFORE THIS BILL. BECOMES LAW
AND SO I THINK IT REALLY
BEHOOVES US TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE
NOW AND I THINK IF IT. REQUIRES
MORE TIME. THEN WE SHOULD TAKE
THAT TIME FOR PASSING THAT BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE. I THINK THAT
THIS IS A- PROPER PIES AND
OTHER. ALL RIGHT. THERE WAS A
MOTION ON TABLE THERE'S A FAIR.
THE MR IF THE TWENTY SOMETHING
OKAY ANYONE ELSE WILL WANT TO
DISCUSS. SURE GLAD. SO THE JUST
A POINT OF CLARIFICATION THE
MOTION ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW
IS TO TAKE AS AMENDMENTS NOW
VERSUS HAVING THE BILL PASSED
AS IT SO IF WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AS IS. MISTER
CALDERON POINTED OUT AND GIVE
YOU A FULL TIME TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE AUTHOR BUT
SINCE THEN THAT COULD BE NO
CORRECT WELL I MEAN I FOR THE
MOTION PERSONS THERE'S A MOTION
ON CABLE WE NEED TO KIND OF THE
MOTION ITSELF. THIS IS A MOST
VISITED IS. THIS IS YEAH
THERE'S A MOTION WELL JUST A CO
THIS IS A MOTION. THIS IS A
MOTION TO PASS THE BILL- WITH
THE AMENDMENT SO MISTER
OBERNOLTE DID YOU DID YOU WANT
TO BE A LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT THAT WITH THE CHANGE
WOULD BE JUST TO. OKAY JUST GO
TO BE SPECIFIC- THERE'S A
SECTION REGARDING- ADVERTISING
TO THE CUSTOMERS IN THE BILL.
AND THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT IS
TO SUBSTITUTE THE WORD INTENDED
FOR THE WORDS REASONABLY
EXPECTED. HE SAID IS I CLEAR TO
EVERYONE. HAVE I'M. IF IT'S
TIME TO MOVE THE BILL TO WITH
THAT ONE OF THEM. RIGHT THANK
YOU. SIR ARM MADAM SECRETARY
FOR THE AMATEUR IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OKAY GO AHEAD SORRY
MIGHT EVERYBODY WITH WHERE- YES
I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING-
AND IT JUST WOULD YOU KNOW WANT
TO EXPRESS MY COMPLETE- YOU
KNOW- APPRECIATION RESPECT THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU MADE TO
IMPROVE THE BILL- I. THINK THIS
IS A MOST. I THINK WE'VE HEARD
THE NUMBERS ON THE THAT A LOT
OF SUPPORT FOR AND THEN THE-
THAT I HAVE A THAT. ONCE IT
GETS OF THIS COMMITTEE I'M NOT
ON APPROPRIATIONS I DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO REALLY HAVE A
PART IN IT KIND OF GOES BACK
INTO THE BLACK BOX. OF STAFF-
YOU KNOW NEGOTIATING WITH
PEOPLE AND THE MEMBERS ARE
ALWAYS THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE NOT HAVING THE
ABILITY O PARTICIPATE IN IT.
AND SO. YEAH WITH THAT. GONNA
SO. THE MOTION- BUT YOU KNOW
JUST WANT TO. SHOW MY
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE- TO IMPROVE THIS
BILL. TO GET ANYONE ELSE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. SO WITH THAT DAHLE
MADAM SECRETARY WHICH YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
MOTION ITSELF TO PASS THE BILL
WITH THE- WITH THE AMENDMENT.
SURE ABSOLUTELY. I THINK IT'LL
THREE MINUTES HOW TO MAKE SURE
THE PRINCE WHAT MAKES YOU THE
PROCEDURES A CORRECTLY. ONLY DO
THAT ONE TAKE. OKAY OKAY. THANK
YOU SO YEAH YEAH MISTER MISTER
CHAIR. MR SCHECK. SO THE
THERE'S JUST ONE BILL NEED TO
VOTE ON JUST ACROSS THE HALL
ACTUALLY THE SENATE G. OF ALONG
BE GO FOR A MOMENT AND THEN
I'LL COME BACK SO IF YOU'RE
NOT- I GUESS ALL KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED BUT- YEAH. ARE YOU
THANK YOU.
YEAH YES. YEAH YEAH
YEAH. WELCOME BACK EVERYONE.
YEAH. SENATOR WELCOME BACK AND-
AT THIS POINT LET'S RESUME OUR
HEARING. SO THIS TIME LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO MR OBERNOLTE. ALL
RIGHT SO I THINK HAVE SOME KIND
ON THE- LEGALLY CORRECT WAY TO
DO THIS SO I'M GOING TO
WITHDRAW MY MOTION. AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED REPLACING THE
REASONABLY EXPECTED TO
LANGUAGE. WITH THE INTENDED TO
LANGUAGE SUGGESTS BY THE
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU THAT MOTION
IS. MADE AND SECONDED SO AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER
TO MADAM SECRETARY CALL ME
MISTER HOLD ON THAT'S- TURN TO
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL FOR
CLOSING. REMARKS FOR YOUR
COLLECTIVE HARD WORK ON THIS
MEASURE OF. YOUR DID YOU CAN BY
THE NUMBER FOR REALLY HARD ON
THE BILL AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE ROOM OF THE A COUPLE
COMMENTS WITH JUST ACCORDED
WE'VE TAKEN ALL REFERENCE TO
CALL IT IT IS THAT WHEN YOUR
TEST RECALL WITH WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR OUR A NINETY IN
EIGHTY CANDOR DIEM FROM THE
SPECIMEN PER. HOWEVER THE
COMPANY TAKES DOESN'T ANNOUNCES
THE DNA THEY ARE SUBJECT TO THE
BILL THEY ARE SUBJECT TO ALL
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL- IT
IN TERMS OF. PRIVACY AND TESS
IT IS FOR THOSE OF YOU OF NOT
IF MAYBE PERHAPS WITH THIS
MEASURE IN PLACE YOU'LL FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE IT ALTHOUGH.
YOU MIGHT EXPECT SOME SURPRISES
TO FIND OUT THAT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT PRESENCE. PORTION
OF YOUR DNA THOSE DRIVE FROM
NEANDERTHALS. AND THEN YOU MAY
ALSO FIND YOUR SPOUSE IS NOT
SURPRISED- WITH THAT I URGE AN
IDOL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATOR AT THIS TIME LET'S TAKE
THE VOTE YEAH. MAN SECRETARY.
WELCOME PLACE. HI RIGHT I. NOW
MEAN ACT YEAH I BERMAN HI
MILLION I'M BARBARA HI I YEAH
REALLY. I IRWIN I DON'T ALL
RIGHT OVER HIGH HI MY YOUR
BILLS OUT TO ZERO YOU VERY YES
I. COMMERCE I THINK THERE'S
MISTER GALLAGHER STILL NOT HERE
YET. HOW FIFTH. I THANK YOU
EXACTLY THANK YOU. AND THE KEY
IN. SAVE OKAY TWENTY FIVE IT I
JUST YEAH. THE POLICY HAS
WIDELY AS WILL DRAW OUT A SWORD.
I CLOSING THIS IS. NUMBER THAT
SUMS UP THAT YOU CAN. IT'S
GONNA BE. ACTUALLY BUT- THE
PERSON. WHICH WERE YOU. YEAH.
WE POLITICAL DISTRICT SCHOOL WE
HAVE HAVE ONE FOR STAFF
SERVICES TOTAL ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MINUTES OF EXTRA POINTS.
AND YEAH BUT.
MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.